if 2021 was tough for you
spare a thought for poor old capitalism
after government handouts mass job
losses and pandemic lockdowns the
workforce dragged themselves back to
work
for a bit and then they all started to
quit
economists have called it the great
resignation and it took effect right
across the globe dub the great
resignation the exodus of workers has
left millions of jobs unfilled and
created hiring challenges for companies
it's still not clear if this was a post
lockdown burnout some sort of massive
cultural shift or just workshop gen zias
not a single mask and a huge party
you know we're in the middle of a panty
right
at the start of the year the global
economy was on life support governments
pumped cash into industries and handed
out cash to anyone who couldn't go to
work because of covid meanwhile the
super rich were obviously still
raking it in figures in 2021 showed that
since the start of the global pandemic 5
million extra millionaires have been
made
something clearly wasn't adding up so
the plebs fought back
the popular subreddit wall street bets
got proactive and went head to head with
hedge funds
who they believed were cashing in on the
failure of popular video game store
gamestop and meme stocks were born when
trading starts it is important to buy
low and sell high yeah i knew that
redditor investors piled into the rescue
and pushed gamestop stock price so high
so fast hedge fund short sellers were
wiped out by the 28th of february
gamestop was trading at 483
up from
1725 at the beginning of the month it
was a david and goliath story and david
appeared to be winning until goliath's
best mate that's the financial
regulators started a crackdown
[Music]
mean manipulation bad
hedge fund manipulation
good
fire
our troops just do it
following the gamestop saga millennials
and gen zeus were on the lookout for the
next get rich quick scheme enter the
doge father elon musk uh where are the
aliens
who shepherded in a new era for
cryptocurrencies by putting his backing
behind the dog-based dogecoin
musk's company tesla had also announced
in february that it had purchased 1.5
billion dollars worth of bitcoin and
would soon be accepting it as payment
for teslas tesla in a new filing says
that they've updated their investment
policy to provide them with more
flexibility to are you ready for this
be able to buy bitcoin three months
later though he reversed faster than an
out-of-control model t and called the
whole cryptocurrency thing a hustle on
live tv what do you make of that word
hustle was he serious or was he joking
he pretty much destroyed the value of
dogecoin sent bitcoin crashing again and
global hacktivist group anonymous
declared the billionaire his mortal
enemy
cue the summer and the world watched two
of the world's richest billionaires
compare rockets richard branson
eventually won breaching the earth's
atmosphere on the 11th of july but was
quickly followed by bezos nine days
later bezos disputes this and says that
richard branson only managed to insert
the tip of his rocket into space whereas
his blue origin spaceship went all the
way
musk didn't bother with this particular
space race he was too busy getting rich
his personal fortune went interstellar
all the way up to around 185 billion
dollars but musk's favorite pastime
throughout 2021 remained baiting bezos
you're competing with the likes of jeff
bezos
in jeffree
the two men traded places as the world's
richest man throughout the year bezos
fought valiantly in the courtroom
looking to sue both nasa and spacex over
contracts whereas musk fought dirty
online with a string of tweets aimed at
the amazon ceo bezos lost in such a
modern way though musk tweeted a silver
medal emoji at him and that zinger that
labeled him as second best was pretty
hard to come back from but he was also
very quick to point out the difference
between space and orbit suggesting that
perhaps what blue origin pulled off is
somewhat easier is he right about that
the what spacex is trying to do is
actually very similar
in the month of september alone 4.4
million americans resigned and across
the globe it was a similar picture with
the pandemic changing the way that
people see work
or the lack of work in october joe
biden's apparent plan to safeguard the
u.s supply chain was undermined by a
lack of workers specifically haulage
drivers
businesses were extending working hours
to ease backlogs but in fairness to
empty shelves joe the supply chain
issues were global the bottleneck was so
bad for the u.s and europe that it
slowed the post-pandemic economic
recovery but it's the fear of inflation
keeping the economists awake right now
or anyone doing the food shop for that
matter in october it reached four
percent in the uk and europe and over
6.2 percent in the us worst hit were gas
prices which rose 250
from january to december because of a
worldwide strain on supplies
and as the year came to an end the king
of hot air musk once again decided to
destabilize the market using his twitter
account on the 6th of november he asked
his followers if he should sell 10 of
his tesla stocks to pay his taxes he
also admitted that he composes most of
his tweets while sitting on the toilet
[Laughter]
musk was almost instantly sued by jp
morgan for violating stock contracts but
the billionaire couldn't care less
because he was closing up the year with
almost 300 billion dollars to his name
if you are following that's over a
hundred billion more than he started the
year with
[Laughter]
but even with all the money in the world
musk can't solve everything
on the 30th of november he emailed
spacex employees saying that the company
could go bankrupt if he didn't have a
major breakthrough in its plan to send
humans to mars days later the chief of
the european space agency
urged european leaders to stop allowing
musk to make the rules of space uh some
people think i'm an alien so we could
have a much tougher 2022. lurking in the
background is capitalist outlier china
with some major issues in its real
estate market for months chinese firm
evergrand which is the world's most
in-debt property developer has warned
that it may not be able to pay off its
debts it's still not clear going into
2022 whether everground's potential
demise could create another lehman
brothers moment for the global economy
but hey something to look forward to
clearly capitalism isn't working for
everyone because closing out the year
inequality remains on the rise while
global billionaires got 3.9
trillion dollars richer this year global
workers combined earnings fell by 3.7
trillion dollars according to the
international labor organization happy
new year everyone
you